From vengeful fathers to parasitic aliens,
some famous movies just come before their time.
These horror movies are the scream of the
crop of box office flops.
The Sam Neill and Laurence Fishburne-led horror
Event Horizon is nothing short of an unforgettable
descent into hellish madness.
The film follows the crew of a starship in
the year 2047, which is tasked with answering
the distress signal of another space-faring
vessel called the Event Horizon.
This mysterious ship had suddenly disappeared
seven years prior during its maiden voyage
and has now eerily reappeared in orbit around
Neptune.
What the crew finds on the Event Horizon is
the stuff of nightmares.
The crew has been massacred, and the ship's
visual records depict the crew members losing
their minds and engaging in sexual activity
and body mutilation.
The rescue crew then begins seeing horrific
hallucinations that recall their own individual histories.
The mysteries of the Event Horizon all revolve
around its strange disappearance.
Experimental space travel effectively took
the ship to another dimension: Hell.
"Where we're going, we won't need eyes to
see."
Anderson was riding high after the success
of the 1995 movie adaptation of the popular
video game "Mortal Kombat" but shifting from
PG-13 material to R-rated horror proved to
be financially detrimental for the director.
Upon its 1997 release, Event Horizon only
grossed nearly $42 million worldwide against
a $60 million budget.
Critically, it was panned for its excessive
gore according to the Rotten Tomatoes Critics Consensus.
However, horror fans began flocking to the
film in droves as years passed, causing multiple
home editions to be released and spurring
on another examination of the film's critical standing.
Even casual film fans around at the time can
recall the stir generated by The Sixth Sense.
The 1999 film about a young boy who can see
dead people put director M. Night Shyamalan
on the map.
However, there was another film released that
year featuring a protagonist who could see
the dead, and it was fatefully overshadowed
by the swelling popularity of "The Sixth Sense."
In "Stir of Echoes," Tom Witzky, played by
Kevin Bacon, is a blue collar phone line repairman
working in the suburbs of Chicago.
He's a skeptic of the supernatural but agrees
to allow his sister-in-law to hypnotize him.
During the alleged hypnosis, she suggests
that Tom be more "open-minded."
From this point forward, he begins seeing
visions of a ghostly apparition of a 17-year-old
girl, who wants Tom to help her complete some
unfinished business.
While the film wasn't a complete financial
failure, it wasn't a success either and only
garnered a $21 million gross, according to
Box Office Mojo.
The film actually received praise from critics
thanks to its great cast, tension-filled story,
and solid source material, as it's based on
horror master Richard Matheson's 1958 novel
A Stir of Echoes.
However, many noted that it was just released
too closely to The Sixth Sense since it came
out just a month after Shyamalan's hit.
The film simply suffered from hitting the
big screen at the wrong time.
But once "The Sixth Sense" phenomenon died
down, horror fans were able to rediscover
"Stir of Echoes" after its home video release.
Despite its middling Rotten Tomatoes scores,
Stir of Echoes continues to be a subject of
discussion for film critics and horror fans
alike.
Based on Jeff VanderMeer's novel of the same
name, the Alex Garland-directed sci-fi psychological
horror "Annihilation" perplexed movie-goers
with its enigmatic story and underlying philosophy.
The film posits that alien contact might not
be the cut-and-dry scenario we've always envisioned.
A meteor crash lands on Earth and creates
an ever-expanding zone the government has
dubbed "the Shimmer."
Those who've gone inside the Shimmer haven't
returned, until one soldier named Kane, played
by Oscar Isaac finally does.
However, he's been affected by the zone and
enters a coma.
His wife Lena, played by Natalie Portman,
is a biologist and volunteers to join an expedition
into the Shimmer in hopes of finding answers
about her husband's condition.
"When did he arrive back home?"
"I wanna see a lawyer."
"You're not gonna be able to see a lawyer."
What the group finds is that life inside the
Shimmer has been mutated.
Horrific animal monstrosities attack the group.
They even find the bodies of those who have
gone before, albeit heavily disfigured.
As Lena makes her way to ground zero, she
begins to learn a bit about herself and her
relationship with her husband.
While Annihilation may have been a critical
darling for its provocative themes, the audiences
simply didn't show up.
With a production budget of $40 million and
a worldwide gross of $43 million, the studio
likely lost money once marketing costs were
factored in.
Publications like Indiewire and The Guardian
argued that the movie suffered because of
the studio's fear of not seeing immediate
returns, which meant it didn't get time to
build an audience.
However, thanks to the source material's popularity
among sci-fi readers and the film's release
on Netflix overseas, Annihilation found a
second chance at life with its streaming release.
If you have a tough stomach, then maybe you
can handle the grisly imagery of the 2015
western horror Bone Tomahawk.
It's the 1890s and Sheriff Franklin Hunt learns
that a tribe of cannibalistic cave-dwellers
who have been shunned by other indigenous
communities are the likely culprits of the
recent kidnappings of three people.
The Sheriff, played by Kurt Russell, sets
out on a rescue mission with local gunslinger
John Brooder, played by Matthew Fox, and Deputy
Chicory, played by Richard Jenkins.
Also along for the journey is the injured
Arthur O'Dwyer, played by Patrick Wilson,
whose wife is one of the people that has been
captured.
What they encounter, however, is the stuff
of nightmares.
While some horror fans can enjoy over-the-top
gore in a campy slasher, the violence in this
film is visceral, grimy, and jarring.
Don't say you weren't warned.
Bone Tomahawk received critical praise, and
even has a certified fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Most enjoyed the slow-burn that paid off with
the intense tension and horrors of the third act.
It's hard to say that this film was a total
flop, considering it only received a limited
theatrical release that made over $475,000
in ticket sales, according to The Numbers.
For a release plan like this, it was always
intended to play the long game.
While the ticket sales were mighty low, home
video sales spiked due to good word of mouth
which, according to The Guardian, ensured
that the film was ultimately profitable in
the long run.
When you hear the name Peter Jackson, you
likely think of his big budget epics like
The Lord of the Rings trilogy or King Kong.
For this reason, many have been left in the
dark about Jackson's zombie horror comedy
film, Braindead, which was released in North
America with the title Dead Alive.
This film relishes in its namesake and brings
buckets full of gore and gross-out practical
effects to its ridiculous story.
Lionel, played by Timothy Balme, is a young
man, who is taking care of his mother Vera,
played by Elizabeth Moody.
Unfortunately for Lionel, Vera is extremely
overbearing and wants to dominate Lionel's
life at every turn.
When Lionel lands a date with a young lady
he takes to the Wellington Zoo, his mother
follows them.
While there, she is bitten by a repulsive
creature.
Vera soon succumbs to an illness stemming
from the bite that turns her into a zombie.
She winds up infecting countless others and
poor Lionel is left to deal with the burgeoning
undead situation.
The film only grossed $242,623 at the North
American box office, according to Box Office Mojo.
However, the film became such a cult hit with
horror fans that it has continually been rereleased
on several platforms including VHS, Laserdisc,
DVD, and Blu Ray.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Jackson
wants to use his super technologically advanced
Weta Digital VFX studio to remaster the film
for a 4K release.
Dead Alive is an absolute blast, but just
make sure you're not eating anything while
viewing this romp.
The slasher subgenre of horror wouldn't be
what it is today without John Carpenter's
iconic 1978 film, Halloween.
The movie created a larger-than-life movie
monster in the form of the twisted serial
killer, Michael Myers.
The indie film's popularity prompted a sequel
that was released in 1981 and directed by
Rick Rosenthal.
With Michael Myers established as a symbol
of horror, one would think that a three-quel
would center around his terrifying return.
Instead, the filmmakers and producers opted
for an anthology approach to the Halloween
series, where each film would tell a different
story on Halloween.
Carpenter felt that Michael Myers' story was
complete with Halloween II, so Halloween III
focused on a new cast of characters and a
Michael Myers-free tale.
The problem is that the franchise already
had two films under its belt featuring Michael Myers.
Audiences had inextricably linked the killer
with the Halloween name.
Once movie goers realized he wasn't featured
in the third installment, the film's box office
performance waned significantly.
Box Office Mojo reports that Halloween III
received a paltry $14 million gross compared
to the $25 million of its predecessor and
$47 million of the first film.
Such a significant decrease in profit prompted
filmmakers to revert back to Michael Myers
with the fourth installment.
"Michael…"
Halloween III ditched the slasher genre entirely
and embraced a different kind of horror that
straddles the lines between the supernatural
and sci-fi: Haunted masks imprinted with a
villainous company's microchip wreak havoc
on an unsuspecting population.
In recent years, fans have returned to the
film praising its unique narrative.
The film has seen new releases, including
a 4K release from Shout Factory.
Director Sam Raimi is no stranger to horror,
with his Evil Dead franchise counted among
one of the most beloved of the genre.
In this installment, we follow Ash, played
by Bruce Campbell, a demon-slaying, chainsaw-wielding
hero whose ego rivals only his own penchant
for survival.
While 1981's Evil Dead started out as a small
indie horror film, it quickly gained traction
and led to the 1986 sequel Evil Dead II: Dead
by Dawn, which moved from pure horror to a
horror-comedy combination that fans have affectionately
dubbed as "splatstick."
It was only a matter of time before the franchise
continued, which it did with 1993's Army of Darkness.
This film pits Ash against the deadites of
old in a medieval civilization.
Ash must live up to his name as the prophesied
champion and vanquish evil.
While the film had the biggest budget of the
original trilogy, it didn't exactly bring
home the bacon during its theatrical run.
Despite its $11 million budget, Army of Darkness
only pulled in a measly $11.5 million in North
America and $21.5 million worldwide.
Still, like the film that started it all,
Army of Darkness became a cult classic.
In fact, Army of Darkness on home video became
a gateway for a whole new generation to discover
the Evil Dead films.
Eventually, fan fervor pushed interested parties
into making a successful reboot film in 2013,
as well as the Starz's TV series Ash vs Evil
Dead.
There's more "Evil Dead" on the way, as Evil
Dead Rise is scheduled to hit theaters in
the spring of 2023.
There's nothing quite like a good old fashioned
story of revenge and murder, and 1988's Pumpkinhead
serves up vengeance nice and cold.
Ed Harley, played by Lance Henriksen, is a
widower and single parent of his young son
Billy, played by Matthew Hurley.
One day, while Ed is away for work, a group
of misfit teens begin to pick on Billy.
They accidentally fatally injure the boy and
flee the scene.
When Ed returns, he finds his deceased son
and soon learns who killed Billy.
The grieving Ed visits a witch and asks her
to help him seek vengeance upon the teens.
"You called upon this thing, in that man's
name, and that man, he'd be avenged."
She summons a demonic creature known as Pumpkinhead,
who systematically hunts and kills the teens
one by one.
This is another film that suffered because
it was released in a limited number of theaters,
which led to Pumpkinhead only grossing $4
million at the box office as a result.
However, the film eventually found success
through home video releases, as new fans discovered
this terrifying and emotional film directed
by Stan Winston, the special effects mastermind
behind Aliens and The Terminator.
Its home video success enabled the film to
receive a handful of sequels which, unfortunately,
don't remotely live up to the original film.
George A. Romero, the father of the modern
zombie, is a titan among horror fandom. 1968's
Night of the Living Dead became memorable
for its graphic violence and depiction of
a world besieged by the cannibalistic undead.
In many ways, it was a first of its kind.
The horror maestro succeeded that first outing
with 1978's Dawn of the Dead, a zombie horror
based in a mall, rife with biting commentary
on commercialism.
Romero then plunged ahead with 1985's Day
of the Dead, which condemned the U.S. military's
might and penchant for shooting first and
asking questions later.
Day of the Dead takes place in a bunker, where
a group of scientists and soldiers try to
survive and find a cure for the zombie plague,
but it turns out, the human threat is almost
as serious as the zombie one.
"We need each other.
Can't we just get along—"
"You need us, the way I see it, lady.
I'm not so sure we need you at all."
Initially, the film only pulled in a worldwide
total of $5 million against a $3.5 million
budget, according to Box Office Mojo.
However, according to PopMatters, it got rejuvenated
through home video platforms including VHS
and DVD.
Day of the Dead garnered critical praise for
Romero's unflinching perception of society,
as well as for its horrific gore effects produced
by horror legend Tom Savini.
While Romero continued his Night of the Living
Dead series with more films over the years,
Day of the Dead capped off the best trilogy
of the bunch.
You're Next is a modern slasher film that
takes the Scream and Halloween murder games
to the next level.
Erin is a young Australian woman who accompanies
her boyfriend Crispin Davison to his family
reunion at their vacation home in Missouri.
The family aren't exactly friendly or agreeable
with one another.
Before long, masked killers begin assaulting
the home, killing everyone one by one.
Erin attempts to survive the onslaught of
terror with all the skills she has, as she
gets to the bottom of the heinous plan carried
out against the Davison family.
The film features over-the-top death traps
and merciless assaults with plenty of blood
to go around.
You're Next received mostly positive reviews
from the critics thanks to its fresh take
on the "final girl" trope.
Rotten Tomatoes Critics' Consensus praised
the film in particular, calling it an "energetic
and effective mix of brutal gore and pitch
black humor."
"I just think that is just the height of the
artform these days."
However, it didn't exactly land well at the
box office, only making $26 million worldwide,
according to Box Office Mojo.
The film has gotten more attention since its
home video release and placement on various
streaming services.
Like several of these beloved cult horror
films, You're Next has benefited from the
modern convenience of in-home streaming services,
which has turned it into a modern slasher
that many people love.
It's also a notable stepping stone in director
Adam Wingard's career, who's since gone on
to direct much larger productions such as
Godzilla vs. Kong.
John Carpenter's The Thing tells the story
of a hostile alien infiltrating a crew in
Antarctica on a microscopic level.
The alien's cells assimilate the host they've
infected and replace the living organism's
cells with its own.
Led by MacReady, played by Kurt Russell, the
crew attempts to figure out who's real and
who's a hideous alien in disguise.
The growing confusion creates an unsettling
fear and sense of anxiety and dread that's
largely unmatched in the horror genre.
Despite the film's status as a horror legend
these days, it was instantly dismissed by
critics upon its release in 1982.
Many were put off by the gore and practical
effects that accentuate the visceral grotesque
horror of the alien Thing, and they believed
the film to be a soulless cash-in on the attraction
to excess violence in cinema.
Furthermore, the plot was accused of being
stale and too simplistic.
Alan Spencer wrote for Starlog Magazine that
The Thing is a "little more than two hours
of makeup test footage" and heavily criticized
Carpenter for the film's lack of story and vision.
Evidently, audiences were also turned off
by Carpenter's body horror, as Box Office
Mojo reports the film made just $19.6 million
at the box office.
In the modern age, the film has been regarded
quite differently.
Many have revisited its cultural impact on
horror, with Wired calling it a "paranoid
classic" and Inverse claiming that it raised
the bar for sci-fi.
Guillermo del Toro wrote a series of tweets
praising Carpenter and The Thing, writing,
Slither is an over-the-top black comedy horror
film directed and written by James Gunn that
does not disappoint in the entertainment department.
Whether you come away from this flick hating
it or loving it, there's never a dull moment.
A meteorite introduces an alien parasite into
a small town in South Carolina, which promptly
infects a man named Grant Grant.
The alien assumes control of his body and
is able to hideously transform and sprout
tentacles.
The possessed Grant Grant abducts a woman
and infects her, forcing her to breed alien
larvae.
When the police get involved, the townsfolk
focus on locating Grant and stopping the transformation
of local residents.
Although it was a critical success, Slither
was a box office failure, raking in only $12.8
million against a $15 million budget.
In fact, the reports of the film's financial
failure were so abysmal that The Hollywood
Reporter speculated that the film may spell
the end for the horror-comedy sub-genre for
quite some time.
In the same article, horror director Eli Roth
commented on the dicey nature of selling a
horror-comedy film, but he noted the potential
for longevity, saying,
Maybe we're watching it on streaming services
now instead of DVD, but he's not wrong.
It only took a decade for retrospectives to
start churning out reevaluations of the film,
with publications like Entertainment Weekly
calling it a cult classic.